you don't flick he flunked my lights you
bastard Oh everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to seed now this
game is about you exploring an obscure
remote location that was struck by
earthquakes and a hole I love the retro
graphic very Silent Hill esque
I don't know what's lurking in these
woods behind besides this hello someone
playing kickball out there oh that's
good an abandoned building covered in
flies always fun
Oh [ __ ] sweet [ __ ] I was about
to say the same thing yeah I'll better
walk inside and breathe deeply the fumes
yeah I can't crouch oh no I'm still a
lovely bed how many people have been in
that bed
so why am I out here I'm not it didn't
say anything about me being in like a
journalist oh these are graves
well don't mean to disturb the dead but
here I go towards the shovel with the
distinct aim of disturbing the dead why
is this [ __ ] outside of the [ __ ]
covered in what I can only assume to be
buttholes keep going but I gotta go
through the [ __ ] again and I don't
know why I needed to do that in the
first blood ah this [ __ ] door that I
need to [ __ ] I have a key oh there
we go okay we got it
we're gonna go into the basement which
is where I wanted to go why did I go
into the baseball this is not a basement
this is a hole in the ground I'd like to
think I know the difference between a
basement and a hole in the ground but if
you ask me what what the difference is I
actually I think either way we can all
agree that this is unfinished lab sorry
for criticizing your amazing basement
here I'll just keep meandering towards
the danger boy who is uh who's moaning
I've got a lot of experience with
moaning oh that's a bony moaning that's
a mannequin Corey Wilson's head it's
been attached to some kind of puppet
usually that would be the indication
that I need to [ __ ] off when I see a
bathtub in the bottom of a hole in the
ground with the skull and I mannequin
body pretty sure burnisher I should get
the fudge out of here Hey sir excuse me
sir you all right I'm gonna back away
slowly so I don't get chased by you
well it's awfully reassuring that
there's some kind of thumpy thumpy
heartbeat going on in there so I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go away now and then I'm
gonna turn around about half way up this
whole my senses are tingling okay well
they're working load they're all that
behind me oh is it daytime Oh am i
blocked in here all good developments
come to me ah thank you yes this is
exactly what I wanted oh boy oh I move
the trash I need to go up oh fairly I
can never mind
hello shitty dicks was that did I get
some kind of disease I step on a needle
play something could have happened here
whoa did I pull an axe out of the wall I
think I pulled an axe out okay well I
guess we're done then
it's just gonna crash oh okay well
apparently that's just the ending that's
not a crash that's just it ending so I'm
gonna all right that was too short so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna play
another game that may not be all that
high quality I mean that game was fine
it was building somewhere and I liked
the UH
I liked the ambience that he was doing
but now I'm gonna play a game called
they come at poop time and I didn't know
if I was gonna be able to play this but
I am so glad ah yes there are four
enemies one in the sink one in the
window one in the store sink enemy pops
up every now and then with a noise when
he's visible press a wall pointing at
him lights must be on window enemy when
he's inside the room looking down at UF
to turn the lights off before he gets
you you'll go away after a while you can
slow him down by looking at him Wally's
outside left door enemy will
occasionally knock on your door you have
to answer them by pressing the e on the
door lights must be on it will right
door enemy he will appear in the mirror
when he's in the mirror you can look at
him and slow him down while he's in this
is this is basically the joy of creation
that's what this is Oh
not while I'm pooping jeez okay all
right wait oh okay
well my poop is in incoming so that's
nice oh the light should probably I just
gotta poop in the dark you don't flicky
flunk my lights you bastard
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've ever seen and oddly enough pretty
scary that's weird
that is weird I gotta admit that is
crazy huh that was better than I ever
expected it to be
are there different rules for every
single oh my god there are make them go
away by throwing toilet paper at them oh
[Music]
my god amazing alright so I'm gonna end
this here but do you guys want to see a
full playthrough they come at poop time
cuz that game is amazing
holy [ __ ] I mean honestly holy [ __ ] that
game was amazing
alright anyway let me know if you want
to see a full playthrough they come at
foo time because that was pretty damn
good and let me know what you think of a
seed 1.2 demo down in the comments below
as well thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next video
[Music]
you